on s'excuse aujourd'hui on se retrouve
sur the sheep avec certain hugo et mika
bonjour bien hojlo santé pour une femme
fait pas grossir ce que je sais c'est un
peu comme murder de garry's mod sauf que
là on a tous une cible assassiné par
exemple au badrutt voyez que doit
assassiner isabel rouette
sauf que je ne sais pas qui c'est tant
que je ne les ai pas vus donc peut-être
que c'est toi voilà c'est elle sur wii
c'est bien paru dans le coup j'en
puisqu'elle a déboîté sécher en état
d'arrestation s'il y avait des caméras
voilà l'exemple parfait du jeu le but
c'est de trouver sa proie de la butte et
ne pas faire de ne pas se faire prendre
par le policier ou par des caméras de
surveillance voilà est dégage direct aux
ânes on la verra plus tard
c'était pas ma froid mais je téléphone
border à moi qui en tire des sous dis
moi quelle [ __ ] on est tous d'amour tu
m'avais comme cible wee aa
tin oo 28 mois je peux métier d'acteur
relata thermique atteint on m a fait
clic droit ça lance des objets après
tout et jure 5 live hier dans la tête je
lance une pelle de mise aux normes est
calme toi ça fait mal vialatte
ça c'était de la triche mais oui mon mec
où je peux être l'apport direct tu te
calmes au québec dont tu as taille et là
j'ai quelques questions verna ouvrés
ouais pas de souci voilà remplace
corinne nom d'un ton las allez dire ici
ou ici où j'ai pas mal à genoux des
boîtes harman kardon est cette dame
malka elle est incroyable est-ce que tu
t'appelles dominique oui mais pas celle
dont julien de merde dégage dégage
faillite faillite non qu'est ce tu veux
faire dans cette chaîne syfy psion fait
ce à quoi tu penses fois on sort
d'accord
je viens avec toi je me tue pas d'un mot
ça vas y petit panneau le maquis d'un
défunt en même temps mais dominique mais
tu es dominique à terme sont à la fois
les bonjour bonjour va parler avec moi
bien
il avait la corde si jamais quelqu'un
arrive à peine à l'extérieur
moi j'avoue à johnny depp à trois tués
par les hommes par contre dans la
grammaire up
comment ça vous avez essayé de me tuer
aussi jodie bonjour au méga qu'imerys
comment tu fais pour sortir après à ok
comme ça aux mondiaux je sors quoi
excusez moi je suis à la recherche d'une
certaine margarita à la voilà à bientôt
oh merde oh oui l'été et non sa voix qui
va tuer mais si vous attendez vous au
site qu'une s'il vous soit attribué
l'idée sur monsieur mba on va voir non
non non non c'était possible allez tous
au pont des oufs est compensé la haye
oui j'suis pas tarder ce battage et
c'est comme ça que je dois tuer c'est
mika qui s'appelle ai dit ok et pas moi
t'es ma cible
[ __ ] biatch maintenant mais curieux
non il dit rien n'est pas de celles ci
mais que tu perdes emmanuel cible
combats d'épées studio tu continues à
nier peinture et eroglu c'est lui qui
doit tuer attentats temps j'ai pas
d'argent au fils de chien jedi nietzsche
tacle raté de peu une course de bateaux
d'avions mais non
laurence et toi là-bas oui si on reste
amer yann lorence je suis pas du tout on
prédateurs au nveau adav laurence en
seriez vous seriez seriez vous l'avez
laurence non comment allez vous mais
qu'est ce tu fais ça a généré plus de
gp2 mais j'ajoute alliés je concentre
dans les bons journaux d'annoncés toi je
vois tu es désolé voilà c'était qui
harriet si je tombe sur toi je te des
boîtes je suis tombé sur toi moi j'ai eu
une sinon pour ceux qui il va rater
haha tu le sais moi j'essaie de pas de
danse et ça va quoi elisabeth vallet moi
mais tu fais quoi des vaches y est
aléatoire et les entreprises avec ta
came bien titan présent l'iccat est ou
non mais je vois qu'on est pas un besoin
si ça va ou quoi ses bas ses fils de
[ __ ]
grâce à quoi tu joues devant la caméra
lamamra de sécurité en prison tu crèves
rien lâcher ça vaut quoi
non non il ya des caméras partout de toc
j'en ai dit sur un ton personnel et une
tête de maman te fait quoi toi monsieur
l'agent il avait rien mais en bas je
suis rien monsieur l'agent il a voulu me
tuer et j'étais bien tenté et ingeborg
optique après faut que je dorme
il n'y a pas un endroit où dormir tu
peut m'amener analystes plémy cas ça là
dedans mika il s'est passé quoi je suis
juste allé dormir et quand je suis sorti
de ma chambre était décédé tu sors quand
prison hugo je te vois arrière gauche
celui-là tobacco bat et dentifrices et
soit entendue copains fallait que je la
mérite
enfin même si sa voix marie élisabeth à
sap via la salle gantois c'est pas toi
ce matin ce matin vous êtes tous les
deux peut-être par contre c'est toi
facebook je te revois lâche merde thomas
la deuxième match
merde il a cette fois jeté une grosse
mais n'importe quoi avec mes habits car
si ça les mecs tu veux pas que non
[Musique]
papa fils de saphir bonjour savoir
atatürk
qu'est ce qui s'est passé et voilà je la
soutiens fin de cette vidéo sur ce deux
chiffres sur ce [ __ ] de bateaux où il
ya le plus de meurtres au monde et ça ça
vous a plu
scanner cpm la vidéo comme d'habitude on
se retrouve très vite et dans une
prochaine news on puisse aller on passe
pas par quatre chemins impression à
kaboul par contre un problème